well I've been on TikTok again
it's Michelle of Lab Muffin Beauty Science
chemistry PhD cosmetic chemist although
these days I feel like what I am is
more of a misinformation connoisseur
I have plunged into the depths of TikTok and I
brought back some gleaming
steaming piles of manure
that is one big pile of
misinformation just goes viral really easily on
TikTok it just hooks into that algorithm so well
last time I did skincare this
time I'm going to debunk hair
care myths using science I'll be
talking about silicone sulfates
preservatives formaldehyde benzene washing
your hair twice heat protectants and more
I've debunked a lot of these on TikTok
and Instagram before but I can never
really go into that much detail cos
those are so short so here we go
dmdm hydantoin is considered
a formaldehyde releaser which
doesn't sound so healthy for your scalp
okay so Dr Tony Youn is a "holistic
plastic surgeon" he's huge on every
platform I've heard that his plastic
surgery stuff is pretty interesting and
informative but he also talks a bit about
beauty products and it's just not correct
he pushes a lot of that clean beauty pseudoscience
maybe because he does have a clean beauty brand
it could also be just an overconfidence
thing that some doctors have this is a
continuation of that and this particular TikTok
is actually part of like my TikTok origin story
back in 2020 I came across this and a bunch
of other videos and they annoyed me so much
I had to join TikTok so before we keep
going I just want to talk a little bit
about medical doctors some people say I'm a bit
too mean to medical doctors who are spreading
misinformation online but I do think that they
really should be held to a higher standard
I get really annoyed because they do
have the privilege of being educated
enough to know better and I also
consider myself being privileged
enough to be able to do a PhD so I also
hold myself to this higher standard
I also know a lot of doctors do a lot of my
friends in real life are doctors and a lot
of my misinformation debunking friends
online are also medical doctors so this
isn't like a blanket diss of doctors it is
just about the ones who say a lot of daft
a lot of doctors do use their authority to
build their platform and again I mean I do
too I think it is valid to tell people where your
expertise is coming from what actually informs
your content and people just do respect titles
and it is kind of handy because you know as an
Asian woman who looks younger than she is and
I mean I've got purple hair I get disrespected
a lot and just waving my PhD around has
become a bit of a shortcut to get people
to actually listen to what I say before they
dismiss me for very superficial reasons it's
kind of like a relatively superficial reason
that undoes some even more superficial reasons
anyway the problem is if you do have that extra
authority bias I really think you need to be more
responsible about what you say that authority
bias that comes with having a title being being
a medical doctor that really superpowers any
misinformation you spread and there are a lot
of doctors who kind of play that up like they
dress in scrubs they film in front of their
wall of medical diplomas and I really just think
that with great power comes great responsibility
dmdm hydantoin is considered
a formaldehyde releaser which
doesn't sound so healthy for your scalp
okay so the way he says this is a
little bit weird like considered
a formaldehyde releaser it just is a
formaldehyde releaser it is how it works
dmdm hydantoin is a preservative like all
of these other preservatives he's also got
these are needed in products to kill microbes
so I mean they are killing living things and
so at some level they are also going to be
harmful to people the trick is to have such
a small amount that is fine for people when
they put it on their skin but also will harm
the microbes when they're swimming in it so
yeah formaldehyde does maybe sound bad and
it is bad if you inhale a whole bunch of it it
does cause nasal cancers I've talked about it
before in my video on the not so pretty
documentary series on that nail episode
but if you have a small enough amount and
you are exposed to it in the right way like
on your skin rather than up your nose then
it is safe this is something called hazard
versus risk so hazard is something that's
harmful in some way but the actual risk how
much in danger you are that also depends
on exposure so if your exposure is really
low even if the hazard is high together that
can mean that your risk is still really low
so you can look at my video on clean
beauty which talks a lot more about
that I've got a toxicologist there
explaining all of these principles
so formaldehyde is actually also in
lots of living things like we produce
it inside our bodies it's in things like
pears we actually produce about 50 g of
formaldehyde a day which is like 1/5 of a
cup it's not that great for us our bodies
have evolved a lot of systems to deal
with it and limit its damage but the
amount on your scalp is like a fraction of of a
milligram it is really just not that big a deal
and I mean he should know this because he is a
plastic surgeon he's familiar with Botox and the
logic is exactly the same so Botox if you didn't
know is one of the most toxic substances in the
world possibly the most toxic something like a
few kilograms of it can kill everyone on Earth
but at the same time millions of people have
had it injected into their face and it's been
fine because of exposure it's being injected
in a low enough amount at the right place
now this thing where he says formaldehyde
doesn't sound so healthy toxicology and
biology isn't about how something sounds it's
not about you know the feels or The Vibes
I really hope as a doctor he is not going on
how things sound for like freaking surgery I
really hope he's looking at actual evidence
and it's disappointing that he isn't here
so he's really just playing to people's
fears here this is really frustrating
because it is the kind of logic that
antivax anti-science movements use
if something sounds bad it is bad don't bother
looking at the evidence just go with your gut feel
I have a very bad feeling about this
so one of the reasons I am so passionate about
clean beauty is that there are lots of links
between clean beauty and the antivax movement
especially with the whole measles vaccine thing
with autism back in the early 2000s and one of
the links is actually formaldehyde if you look
at infographics for clean beauty and anti
vax they are just like very very similar
tiny amounts of formaldehyde are in lots of
vaccines and you see it all the time on these
like infographics it will say things like you
know this is so bad it's bad for you it gives
you cancer you don't want to inject it into
your baby you also just don't want to put it
on your scalp according to the same logic
and it drives me a bit mad that people who
are into public health don't really see
this as what I think is a huge problem
we have huge beauty stores like Ulta
and Sephora just teaching a really
big chunk of the population this logic
from their early teens this whole idea
that if it has formaldehyde then it
is unclean and you need to avoid it
it's going to be really hard to undo all
this indoctrination by the time someone
is having a baby and they're asked
whether or not they want to inject
a vaccine with a tiny tiny amount of
formaldehyde into their precious baby
and there actually is a class
action lawsuit going on right now
all right so class action lawsuits get
brought up a lot in social media posts
about different ingredients the thing is
anyone can bring a class action lawsuit
that just doesn't really tell you if they
have a good case and even if they do end
up settling and the people end up getting a
bunch of money it's not an admission of guilt
settlements happen all the time for other
reasons like avoiding a long protracted
expensive lawsuit and just all the bad
publicity that gets wrapped up into that
so for these dmdm hydantoin lawsuits it does
mostly just seem to be people with allergies
there is a small percentage of the population
allergic to most ingredients so for formaldehyde
it seems to be somewhere around 1% of people so
if you are allergic to formaldehyde it can cause
itching and hair loss but that doesn't mean
it's causing hair loss for people who aren't
allergic allergies are when your body is just
overreacting to something that is normally safe
now I have noticed that there's been a lot
more hair loss lawsuits lately with lots
of brands whose formulas haven't actually
changed much in years maybe decades and I
think the explanation that makes the most sense
is the pandemic covid is linked to hair loss
and a lot of people even if they haven't
had covid they've been stressed which is
also linked to hair loss and hair loss just
varies over time as well so people tend to
lose more hair in Spring and lose less hair
in Autumn there's also things like pregnancy
so there are a lot of things that can cause
hair loss and saying that it is definitely
linked to one thing like a shampoo or a specific
ingredient in a shampoo that is just really
difficult to do without looking at science so
it's really just correlation isn't causation
I can't believe how long I've taken
debunking this 10-second video there's
something called brandolini's law which
is also called the BS asymmetry principle
basically it just says it takes an order
of magnitude like 10 times more effort to
debunk misinformation than to spread
it and it is always harder to debunk
when it's someone who you would expect to be
well informed like a medical doctor and then
on top of that there's just so many more
non doctor people spreading misinformation
so support me by liking and subscribing I swear
I didn't say that just to get in this pitch
there's actually a really good reason your
shampoo bottle says rinse and repeat on the
back and no it's not just manufacturer's way
to sell more shampoo but I used to think the
same thing let me take you over to my
how shampoo works poster and yes I made
this cuz I'm a nerd and I love talking about
shampoo but basically this is why it works
okay when you are you know needing to shower you
have a dirty scalp you're going to have sebum
you're going to have oil on it what happens is
that when you shampoo you're going to have these
little purple things that are called surfactants
they're going to attach themselves to the dead
skin cells the oil the grime the dirt all of that
and it's going to create what's called a micelle
this micelle is hydrophobic and hydrophilic
and it's going to release when the water that
you wash it off with touches that okay so
then it's going to wash way down the drain
a lot of people tagged me in this
video because she claims that it's
just how science works you have to
wash your hair twice so my PhD is
partly in supramolecular chemistry which
is the science of how molecules interact
without actually going through a chemical
reaction which is what all of this stuff is
now I am all for making your own diagrams
when you don't like the ones that already
exist I do it all the time but I don't
love her explanation and I wonder if
this is actually why she is confused when
you're washing your hair and you've got
the surfactant interacting with the oils
it actually breaks up into lots of little
emulsion droplets which aren't really called
micelles but that is really just a technicality
it's not all lifting off in
one giant blob it's just lots
of little dots and it suspends
before you start washing it off
it isn't like the water hits it and then
it suddenly like lifts off or something
it doesn't suddenly release because there is
already water around it's already touching it
it is already going to be lifting
off and turning into droplets
here's the thing your scalp is not totally clean
after this one process so after most of those get
washed away there's still going to be a little
bit of dirt and grime and dead skin cells on
your scalp okay that's just how it is and you need
to repeat so at that point you can get all of the
oil surfactants are going to create a micelle
and then the micelle is going to wash it away
and at the end of your second wash you're going to
feel a huge difference compared to the first wash
there is nothing in the science that
says one wash with surfactants can't
lift off all the oil and dirt it is just
the same chemistry as washing plates
when you're washing plates you don't
necessarily need to wash them twice
sometimes you do it depends on how dirty it is
how dirty your plates or your hair is it depends
on your technique it depends on what products
you're using if you're using a product that
just isn't very good at cleaning or if you
didn't use enough of the product even things
like the temperature of your water will make a
difference so you might find that your hair is
better if you wash twice but most shampoos
are designed to wash off with just one wash
now I did get a bunch of people asking me if I
don't need to wash my hair twice why do I get
more foam on the second shampoo so the reason
you get less foam is because the surfactants
are in charge of both lifting the oil off
your hair as well as forming foam so if you
have more surfactants tied up in the oil you're
going to have less to create foam but the thing
is this doesn't actually tell you anything about
whether or not the second washes is doing anything
so all this tells you is that in your first
wash you have some of these surfactants tied
up in the oil you have less surfactants tied up
in the oil in the second wash but you could also
just have no oil even if the second wash was
doing nothing you would still get more foam
if you washed your hair a third time and
you got a lot more foam than the second
wash then that tells you your second wash
was doing something the third wash tells you
nothing about the third wash the second wash
foam tells you nothing about the second wash
and it's interesting that she says this
at the start like all shampoos say to
rinse and repeats but most shampoos that
I've looked at in my collection most of
them say to repeat if necessary if
they even mention repeating at all
someone in my comments mentioned that
the shampoo bottle she's holding is
Monat which is a multi-level marketing
brand she is selling it and I've noticed
that Monat sellers tend to spread
a bunch of misinformation online
I don't know if it's officially sanctioned or
if it's just you know people being creative
and entrepreneurial but honestly from what
I've heard of this company I wouldn't put
it past them to just have this on
the shampoo to make you buy more
so yeah this is an example of like
the bad Monat tests that they've been
spreading the thinking which if you can
call it that is that if you get a cotton
bud and you put the heat protectant on
it and then try to light it on fire it
won't light if it's a good heat protectant
but that is not how heat protectants work
a hair stylist online got her toddler
to explain it and he actually explained
this really well so I'm going to
play that I'm going to cover up his
face cuz it's kind of weird to have
someone else's toddler in your video
hi hairdressers just because something
isn't flame retardant that doesn't mean
that they're not heat retardant heat isn't fire
yes so that is literally it if you
have a heat protectant it spreads
heat out really nicely and so you're
not getting hot spots in your hair
fire is combustion it's something reacting
with oxygen and burning so cotton for example
is actually used in oven mitts it's
really good at protecting your hands
from fire but it's going to burn they are two
completely different properties of substances
most of the time what these videos are
actually showing is that some products
contain water which is really good at not
lighting and other things will contain
oil or alcohol and they will light on
fire it is just a test for combustion
so I guess the ironic thing is that too much
water is actually bad in heat protectants because
water can absorb into hair and boil it doesn't
evaporate as easily as alcohol but it boils a
lot more easily than oil and so what happens is
inside your hair it can boil explosively so it
goes kind of like popcorn and it causes something
called bubble hair which is literally like popcorn
three high street shampoos that you
need to avoid like the plague number
one head and shoulders there are much
better shampoos that you can use for
dandruff that you can get from your local pharmacy
Head and Shoulders contain sulfates which can
dry out the scalp and over time leave your hair
looking dull and dry also Head and Shoulders
can lead to color fade outs if you spent dollar
dollar dollar on having amazing dyed hair this
may fade it a lot quicker than you want it to go
something that I've noticed is so many
of these videos warning people to stay
away from particular hair care products
they always say things like avoid these
like the plague which I guess people
aren't really avoiding the plague but
also things like avoid at all costs
which is a really common thing I see
I sort of half expected her to say this I don't
know why I never hear this phrase in real life
and my conspiracy theory is that they're usually
about to recommend a really expensive alternative
that maybe they are selling in their links and so
they kind of want to prep you with the word cost
anyway Head and Shoulders is one of those
brands that a lot of people keep warning
people about and I think it is because it is
a really nice affordable brand and yes there
are other options for dandruff but Head and
Shoulders is a really solid choice they are
a Proctor and Gamble brand they invented a lot
of new technology around getting zinc pyrithione
which is the active ingredient that kills the
fungus that is causing the dandruff they've
got a lot of tech on getting that to deposit
on the scalp so it is really not a bad choice
now sulfates is one of my like passion
topics they are not automatically harsh
and stripping I've talked about
it in my shampoo myths video
the reason is the way surfactants work
to clean your hair is a supramolecular
process it is sort of like
molecular choreography all
of these little tadpoles are working
together to lift the oil off the hair
I keep on showing this diagram
and the lead author of the paper
actually dmed me on Instagram so
hi if you are watching thank you
again for this diagram it is just
so handy for explaining cleaning
so not all of these pink tadpoles are
the same and all these surfactants
are working together in the
product to lift off the oil
in pretty much every shampoo you get these
days you will see multiple surfactants and
so the sulfates if they have sulfates are just
going to be some of these pink tadpoles so how
much a shampoo strips isn't just about
whether or not it has sulfates yes or no
it's also about everything else that's in
there which is the surfactant but also the
other ingredients that aren't shown in this
diagram like polymers they all interact as
well and some of these ingredients can keep
the sulfates from going deeper into hair
or deeper into skin so it's about what the
final combination of everything is overall
it's sort of like Nicolas Cage movies you can't
tell just by whether or not it has Nicolas Cage
or if it's Nicolas Cage free whether or not it
will be a good movie Nicolas Cage good or bad
a challenge certainly but not unsolvable
it's about everything else in the movie
like who the director and the writer are
now if you do have colored hair like me I
think you would probably be better with a color
protection shampoo that is actually optimized
to protect your color Head and Shoulders don't
have one in Australia anymore but someone told
me that they do have one in other countries
and there's a Good Housekeeping test
where they tried lots of different
color protection shampoos the one that
stripped dye the least had sulfates in it
now I did get a lot of comments saying that
people love sulfates because they get their
hair clean and I do appreciate the energy
but it still isn't about sulfates or not
it is still the overall formula
that's important you can make a
really mild sulfate shampoo you can make
a really stripping sulfate free shampoo
number two Tresemme now these products
contain sulfates again dry out the
hair but also contain silicone which
can build up on the scalp and cause
itchiness and irritation of the scalp
so I would recommend not to use Tresemme
so silicone can build up on the scalp it's
just like any other conditioning ingredient
but generally it's not an issue with shampoos
there really isn't that much conditioning in
shampoos there's really just enough silicones
to make your hair not tangle when you're washing
you do need a bit of conditioning agent in
shampoos otherwise your hair gets really
tangled and matted and damaged because when
your hair is wet the cuticle sticks up a bit
bit more it's going to be rougher it's
going to be a bit more fragile and you
are moving it around a whole bunch so
it is really prone to getting damaged
if different hairs snag against each
other and break off bits of cuticle
now most of the time in shampoos it's
not silicones that are conditioning it's
actually polymers possibly because
people got scared of silicones
I do see a bunch of people saying
why would I want a shampoo that
conditions I just want it to clean and
I get that but if you do try a shampoo
that doesn't have any conditioning
agents it is a horrible experience
number three OGX now this brand which
is quite popular and is available in
most drug stores has actually got an
alleged lawsuit against it now I'm not
sure of the ins and outs but I think it's
because of hair loss or hair thinning now
they do contain chemicals which can be
quite strong on the scalp and can lead
to irritation they do claim to be sulfate
free however but again I would just avoid
this OGX lawsuit is about formaldehyde I
talked about that before but it is kind
of wild to me that we have like a medical
doctor here with a stethoscope and scrubs
she is an aesthetic doctor so I'm not sure
what she's doing with the stethoscope anyway
why would you not at least look it up before
[telling] people to avoid it like the plague
again it is just that lack of responsibility
that's really annoying me having
that doctor's endorsement really
does superpower the misinformation
people are more likely to believe it
I got this comment on a video and I don't
know if this person is joking or not but
this is literally how a lot of people think and
it's not necessarily a bad thing we should be
able to trust experts but but a lot of these
perceived experts are spreading misinformation
and pretending they have the right expertise
to know more about it when they don't and it
is usually all these really affordable brands
that get all these warnings against them and
it's really frustrating because these
drugstore products are good products
and a lot of the alternatives that people are
recommending instead they don't do their own R&D
but they charge so much more and it's just kind
of gross and elitist to me that these people are
trying to get people to spend more money for a
product that will probably have less benefit and
yeah people do get higher commissions and higher
affiliate income off higher priced products
also this is kind of just hilarious
to me but every time I debunk one of
these videos with a side by side do I get
a whole bunch of comments saying something
like her hair is really shiny your hair
is really dull why would I listen to you
and this is just hilarious to me because
I think it's pretty obvious that you know
I'm East Asian my natural hair color is black
bleaching is possibly the most damaging thing
you can do to your hair to get my hair to
this color I had to sit for a full 9-hour
workday at a hair salon that specializes
just in bleaching the crap out of Asian hair
so this was bleached to a level 9 or 10 it is
pretty much a miracle that my hair is still
attached to my head before olaplex really
became a thing a lot of hairdressers would
just refuse to do this a lot of hairdressers
still refuse to do this so it feels a lot like
saying Icelandic people know more than
Australians about sun protection because
Australians have more sun damage and the
amount of exposure and the conditions that
the hair slash skin has gone through is
just so different in the two situations
and honestly before I did this to my hair
it was a lot easier to manage my hair was
always really shiny and it looked fine
but I knew so much less about hair then
compared to now and I'm not saying you have
to have super damaged hair to understand hair
but it does give you an extra incentive to
learn more about how to deal with your hair
anyway the two aren't
correlated it's a weird comment
stop using these products they are ruining
your hair do I even need to go into detail
batiste is far too heavy to be using on your
hair frequently the reason why it's an issue
is cos it's really difficult to completely
shampoo out of your hair unless you're using
a detox shampoo if this isn't washed
out properly it builds up on the scalp
it can block hair follicles and that can
lead to hair loss or lack of hair growth
if we look at what ingredients are
in batiste I'll put them up here
the first three are gases butane
isobutane and propane so they're
just going to evaporate and disappear
so will the alcohol and the fragrance
so the stuff that's left on your scalp we've
got rice starch that's not that hard to wash
off your hair I think we've all seen rice starch
going down the drain when you wash your rice
cocoyl hydrolysed keratin this is
little chunks of keratin protein
attached to fatty acids that's the
cocoyl bit that's generally not that
difficult to wash off the cetrimonium
chloride and distearyldimonium chloride
these two are cationic surfactants they're
really common in conditioners they are
pretty much the most basic type of conditioning
ingredient again they're not really anything that
special and they're not something that
won't wash out without a detox shampoo
she does kind of have a point here which is
that dry shampoo might mean you're washing
your scalp a lot less and then yes buildup
can happen on your scalp and that can mess
up your hair follicles it can also mess
up the microbial balance on your scalp
and this is important because it's one of the
main causes of dandruff this is the yeast and
if you have too much of those they can cause
scalp irritation they eat up things called
triglycerides which are part of your skin
oils they spit out fatty acids and those
can be irritating and that can all lead to
inflammation which can mess with hair growth
but this is with anything that you
spray onto your scalp it's not really
the batiste itself that's an issue but
people who wash their hair less than
they should might be using batiste a lot
because it is such a popular dry shampoo
the only miracle about this is that it's still
being sold this is really really not good for
your hair it has insoluble silicone in
there insoluble silicone is silicone
that cannot be broken down by water which
means it's very very difficult to wash out
silicone is essentially plastic if that builds
up on your hair and you're also heat styling
you're essentially melting your hair just
waiting for it to break off really isn't a
very good conditioner I know it can make your
hair feel great but it's all just superficial
okay there is a lot here she just
kind of rattled off a whole bunch of
really common myths about silicone so I'm
going to try to get through these somehow
so first off silicones aren't plastic
this stuff here is dimethicone you can
see it is a lot more like an oil
it's a liquid plastics are solid
point two this is obviously not in
order silicones do not melt hair
I'm not entirely sure where this comes from
but there is a lot of stuff with hairdressers
saying that when they bleach hair it
heats up and then they can see silicone
dripping off which is an observation
but the explanation isn't quite right
the heating is probably from metal ions in the
hair these can come from dyes or tap water and
that's reacting with some of the ingredients
in bleach but it is not the silicone doing it
silicones are really stable to heat and that
is why they're used in so many heat protection
products they won't react and produce
more heat so with these silicones that
are really unreactive like dimethicone which
is the main one that people mention this with
they can only really get as hot as whatever
hot tool you're using and the reason they work
so well for heat protection is because
they don't react they form a layer that
helps spread out heat more evenly it's sort of
like when you're using a frying pan versus if
you're directly cooking on a fire having
that extra layer there spreading out the
heat - it stops you from getting hot spots
where your hair will just start decomposing
while there are other bits of your hair
that are still too cold and they're not
being styled they're not actually curling
or straightening or whatever you're doing
okay next point um it doesn't condition
well because it is just superficial
superficial conditioning is actually probably
the most important part of conditioning
the reason: things that are on the surface
make your hair feel great is because it's
been smoothed out so when you're touching
your hair your skin all the tiny microscopic
little jagged bits in your skin they're not
getting caught on the rough bits of your hair
and so that means your smooth hair is also more
protected it's not getting caught on brushes
and straighteners it's not getting caught
and getting stretched which is one of the
biggest causes of the damage you get when you're
grooming your hair when you're brushing or styling
she also mentions soluble versus
insoluble silicones and I think
this might come from maybe
the curly hair method thing
this thing in itself has like a lot of layers
first off it doesn't matter if the silicones are
soluble or not you don't need to wash out all of
your conditioner because conditioners they don't
form a continuous film on your hair they form
more sort of like little blobs so it's not like
your conditioning layer is blocking stuff from
going in or out of hair it can just stay there
it's sort of like protective paint on a drink
bottle or something you don't need to like scrub
off all the paint every time and apply more
paint you can just leave the paint on there
now insoluble things wash off hair all
of the time so oils for example aren't
water soluble that is the whole point
of putting the surfactant in the shampoo
they have that oily part which grabs
onto things that are not water soluble
water soluble also doesn't
mean it comes off the hair
more easily so hair is really good
at something called hydrogen bonding
that means it forms these relatively
strong intermolecular interactions
and water is really good at this as well
so ingredients that hydrogen bond
more tend to dissolve better in water
so more hydrogen bonds means that
it mixes better with the water and
spreads out so hyaluronic acid and
citric acid both can form hydrogen
bonds that's why they are water soluble
and that's also how they stick to hair
but it can actually also mean that they stick
to hair too well so some of the most like sticky
haircare ingredients that build up on hair are
actually charged and relatively water soluble
there was no way we were going to get
through a TikTok misinformation video
without Bobby this guy is Bobby
Parish he's also known as flavcity
he usually talks about food and he
talks a lot of pseudo science there
as well and there's a whole bunch
of food science people that I'm
going to put up here who I recommend
who have specifically debunked him
you know those commercials or the A-list actors
waving their hair for Head and Shoulders spoiler
alert they ain't using it and sometimes when
you can't read or pronounce ingredients it
doesn't mean they're bad but in this case
it does these two are harsh preservatives
that are known allergens skin irritant
and neurotoxins I'm sorry put it back
it's kind of nice that he finally admits for
a change that being able to pronounce a word
just doesn't mean very much so these ones
are pretty easy for me methylisothiazolinone
methylchloroisothiazolinone but I
cannot pronounce botanical names
like raspberry is rubus [sad attempts]
a curry plant is [more sad attempts]
anyway I'm pretty sure it is better
for me to eat raspberry and curry
leaves than it is for me to eat a
whole bunch of these two ingredients
and I am actually personally allergic
to these so I kind of feel this these
are preservatives but they're being
phased out because when they were
introduced they sort of caused this
so-called epidemic of allergy and
that word epidemic is is actually used in
the peer-reviewed journals some authors
have actually suggested that these became
more common in products because people like
Bobby were freaking everyone out about parabens
like what he was doing in my last set of videos
parabens actually won the title of
non-allergen of the year in 2019
because they are relatively non-allergenic
compared to these ingredients that might have
replaced them but again even though they
are a more common allergen if you're not
allergic to them you don't really need
to avoid them but these two do tend to
cause you to develop allergies to them
and they're kind of common so if you do
feel itchy with a lot of shampoos and laundry
detergents you might want to look into that
again he is using the ewg database like
last time they are a really crap source
I went into tons of detail about them in my last
misinformation video but basically they are very
much in the business of selling fear their
whole shtick is a bit like please be scared
of all these common things but conveniently we
are the only people protecting you against them
every time you go on their website they just just
give you all these popups for donations and they
seem to have a lot of funding from the organic
industry so obviously having this sort of database
of ingredients to watch out for is just ignoring
the whole idea of hazard not being like risk
the whole idea of dose and exposure
again it is this antivax logic and
it is hard for me to believe that
they're not operating in bad faith
like I mentioned last time they kept on
going on with the whole vaccines cause
autism thing well after it was very obvious
that the whole Wakefield study was just BS
now the funny thing here is is he does
mention neurotoxicity if you look at the
thing he's showing it actually says that it is
a low risk if you look it up in their database
and actually click on it it says that it
is on in vitro tests on mammalian cells
so in other words they must have gotten some
neurons out of some mammals and then chucked
it into like a little bath of MI and again
it is a matter of concentration and exposure
the chance of having like your brain cell
swimming in MI after you use a shampoo is
just super low the ewg have gotten so
lazy with their referencing or maybe
they just got sick of people looking up
the studies and critiquing them because
like "open scientific literature" and then
their data sources are like "open scientific
literature/peer-reviewed literature" that is
just like we looked it up on Google and then
they've got "nlm 2012 PubMed online scientific
bibliography data" that is literally like saying
your source is Google search but it's worse
because it's like Google search from 2012
anyway I found the study it is on rat brain
cells and the concentration of MI where they
saw an effect was 100 micromolar so I got
out my little calculator because you know
Brandolini's Principle I'm going to have
to do way more work than Bobby's doing
it converts to 0.001% MI now in 2010 the US
limited MI to 0.01% now this was a cosmetic
ingredient review recommendation it's
not like a binding law but it is the
sort of thing that you follow if you're a
big brand unless you really want to open
yourself up to litigation so if we have
this maximum recommended concentration
your brain cells would have to be swimming in
the shampoo only diluted by less than 10 times
so a big blob of shampoo in your hand is
5 grams so you would have to be using less
than 1/5th of a cup of water with that giant
blob to get that concentration anyway I would
avoid the ewg and anyone citing it like
the plague I would avoid them at all costs
it absolutely blows my mind that so many women
do not know this but there is an ingredient in
pretty much every shampoo that is destroying your
hair it's called table salt that stuff is in your
shampoo and it's also drying out your hair and
the crazy thing is it's in almost every single
shampoo I've looked at over 2,000 shampoos
and at least 85% of them had table salt in it
if you don't believe me go to your bathroom right
now check your shampoo if you see the ingredient
sodium chloride in there then that is table salt
this one is just kind of hilarious to me like
we are really scraping the bottom of the barrel
here we're trying to freak people out about salt
so yeah sodium chloride is used in a lot
of shampoos because it is a really good
way of thickening up some surfactants so
it is some particular anionic surfactants
like sulfates basically anionic surfactants
are negatively charged and the ions from the
salt will interact with these heads of
the anionic surfactants and it changes
how they're arranged so it makes
the micelles inside your shampoo
sort of turn into long noodle shaped
micelles and those get tangled up more
that means that it becomes a lot thicker they
kind of like get tangled up in each other before
they get poured out and so you end up with a
blob in your hand instead of like water it's
really cool and neat but the amount of salt you
need is actually really low it's usually like
1% or perhaps even less even sweat has more
salt than this sea water has like three times
more plus you also dilute your shampoo before
you put it in your hair and then you wash it
out after maybe a couple of minutes maximum so
it's not like your hair is soaking in the salt
the thing is when you use a product
that contains table salt it will over
time cause your scalp to dry out and this
can cause flaky scalp hair loss and not
only that it also dries out your strands
which can cause split ends breakage and
just brittle hair overall your hair
is getting attacked from all sides
so yeah your hair is not soaking in
the salt your scalp isn't soaking in
it either but even if your scalp was
soaking in the salt the reason that
salt dries out your skin is because of
osmosis that's when water is getting
pulled out because the liquid outside your
cells has like more concentrated salt than
the liquid inside your cells but your
diluted shampoo is really not that salty
if it is drying out your scalp it's probably other
things in there like the surfactant and just the
water from your shower maybe it's like warmer and
just washing out the oils from your scalp that's
going to be making a much bigger difference
than like the tiny tiny sprinkle of salt
okay we're doing it let's talk about
the 1.5 million dry shampoos that have
been recalled in the US and Canada this
past week if you haven't seen tons of dry
shampoos right now are being recalled for having
a cancer-causing ingredient in them called benzene
so yeah this video was back from the recall of
dry shampoo because there were traces of benzene
found in them a whole bunch of products
have been recalled sunscreens as well
and hand sanitizers and they're almost
all because of one lab called Valisure
I've talked about the sunscreen recall
in another video that breaks it down
in a lot more detail but in short the
lab says a lot of really questionable
things that make it really sound
like they're trying to fearmonger
I might do a longer video breaking down
the background behind this lab and some
of their pretty dubious things I don't
know maybe a bit later but the amounts
of benzene found in these products were
really low but like with formaldehyde
it is pretty easy to freak out about
benzene if you don't know a lot about it
back with the sunscreen story a lot
of dermatologists were posting really
fearmongery videos based on that
Valisure press release because
that press release itself was pretty fearmongery
now I don't really blame people for freaking
out a bit when you first hear these sorts of
stories but you should really do a fact
check when these stories come out before
you throw out your products maybe just
put them in the back of a cupboard for
a while until more info comes up and
it gets a bit clearer and you should
definitely not film a video warning
all of your many followers about it
now if you don't know anything about benzene it's
a chemical that's normally found in car emissions
and gasoline it's been found to cause temporary
symptoms of anemia memory loss skin irritation
but the most concerning it's a carcinogen
which means it's a cancer causing agent
so all of the recalls were done out
of that whole abundance of caution
thing the brands all go to lengths
to say that the amounts of benzene
weren't expected to cause any harm and the
Valisure data does actually support that
again check out my older video on benzene
and yes car emissions are one of the big
sources of exposure if you want to drop
your benzene exposure the best thing to
do is actually just not to park your car
in a garage that's attached to your house
even if you inhaled all of the benzene
coming out of one of these products
which is unlikely because you know spray
products go into the air not just all into
your lungs it is still less exposure
than breathing city air for half a day
so all of these effects she's talking about like
anemia memory loss skin irritation cancer all
of these are from occupational exposures to much
higher amounts of benzene again the dose is really
important for your actual risk it's not from
these tiny amounts you getting from a hairspray
and not only are these aerosol cans causing us to
inhale this stuff but your scalp actually absorbs
things into the bloodstream in just 26 seconds
so that crap is all up in your bloodstream
I'm not really sure where this 26 seconds like
factoid comes from but benzene isn't easily
absorbed through your skin or your scalp most of
the exposure you get is mostly through inhalation
and there was actually a study where some
dermatologists got annoyed enough to look
at the blood levels of benzene measured
in people who use different amounts of
sunscreen and they found that there was just
no connection between how much sunscreen you
used and how much benzene you have in
your blood which again given how much
benzene has been found in these products
it's just not really that surprising
and take a look at the first few
ingredients on your dry shampoo
I'm willing to bet it's either propane
butane or isobutane now how this crap is
even allowed in our beauty products beats
me but let me give you a little history
lesson so you can kind of understand how
messed up beauty products in the US are
there is nothing wrong with these ingredients
they are all propellant gases that push the dry
shampoo out of the can and they're not toxic at
sensible amounts just you know don't huff your
can of dry shampoo they're hydrocarbons and
they're the same stuff that you get in like
hot pot gas cans and in cigarette lighters but
this just really has nothing to do with benzene
I think she's just kind of gone down
like this scary names rabbit hole
there has not been a law as to what cannot go
in our beauty products in the US since 1938
84 years ago and the US only has 11 ingredients
banned from our products whereas the UK has over
1,300 ingredients banned from their products
something is just not adding up here like why
there are so many myths about us versus EU
slash UK regulations I talked about some of
these before in my video on EU versus
US sunscreen regulation but this whole
11 versus 1300 banned ingredients thing
this just really doesn't tell you much
unsafe ingredients are banned in both
regions and basically these lists
are just examples of ingredients
that would make a product unsafe
to my understanding the reason the EU/UK
list is longer is mostly just historical
and political reasons when the UK was part
of the EU they used the EU list and then
since brexit they sort of split it and
now the UK list is slowly sort of like
evolving and changing compared to the EU one
basically when the different countries banded
together to form the EU there was like a lot
of smooshing of regulations and so that's why
you find really weird stuff on that list like
things like jet fuel and radioactive materials
so it's just like the EU has a lot more
examples and a lot of these examples have
never actually been in cosmetics they're
just included for weird historical reasons
and the FDA has issued warnings for products
that contain lots of ingredients that aren't
on this 11 banned ingredients list so clearly
there are more than 11 banned ingredients
things like prostaglandin analogues and those
are eyelash growth ingredients that have been
found out side effects they're what's
in bimatoprost and the thing is all of
the ingredients she's mentioned in this
video are allowed in EU and UK products
like butane propane isobutane are commonly
found and even traces of benzene are allowed
and having a recall is actually
a good thing so notice that the
US and Canada did have recalls but the EU
and the UK didn't and this isn't because
there's no benzene in those EU and UK
products based on how the benzene got
into the products it's probably in lots
of different countries' products as well
I know people who work in EU regulations
and they've mentioned that the US does
have a more litigious culture and
that's maybe why the products are
so similar in both regions even though
the regulations do look quite different
but there are new regulations coming
into the US called MoCRA and this will
be nice because it does make the
regulations more similar to the EU
the biggest problem with the US regulations
that I've heard from regulatory people is
that the regulations are pretty unclear
so it's hard for smaller brands to really
understand what they can and can't do what are
good practices when making and launching cosmetics
a lot of those like homemade kitchen products
that you see from small brand selling on places
like Etsy they are sort of like the beauty
equivalent of pink sauce there's just not a
lot of you know normal safety practices going
into making those and this is a lot less of a
problem in Europe because you do need to register
any products that you sell so there is a sort of
at least basic gatekeeping that stops a lot of
people from just launching weird unsafe products
again I think I've managed to make a video that
is like way too long on this I don't know how
I managed to keep all this to like oneish minute
when I was debunking them on TikTok there are just
a lot of layers to all of these myths but yeah a
lot of these videos have had millions of views and
it is really quite scary how this like perfect
mix of fear and short explanations just really
hooks into social media algorithms it's really
easy to get people's attention in a short time
span with this sort of content and most people
do care about their friends and family so when
they see these they will forward it to them and
make sure you know they aren't harming themselves
and all of this sharing and saving is just
rewarded really well by all the platforms
so I guess the message here is just be
really careful when you're sharing scary
videos even if you are doing it with good
intentions which I'm sure most people are
I mean you can share with me so
I can find out more about them
and debunk them but you know don't share share it
if it's something that's scary or surprising that
is like an automatic red flag for misinformation
it's not always the case because scary stories
are sometimes true but most of the time if
something is surprising that means that it isn't
really supported by the body of evidence it's
not a robust finding that's been confirmed
again and again which is how science works
also look for the consensus of relevant
experts and yes we did just see some
people who seem like experts sharing
this information but a lot of the time
medical doctors on social media aren't really
automatically experts on things like toxicology
and cosmetics those aren't really topics that
they learn in any sort of depth in med school
and again there are huge teams of
scientists working at a lot of these
companies the chance that someone
with no training or expertise can
look something up on an app and find out
it's toxic in 5 seconds it's just really
not something that all of these scientists
have missed or they're staying quiet about
it's just really really improbable
that there's this huge conspiracy
going on so most of the time if a bunch of
relevant experts are overwhelmingly saying
the same thing it is probably going to
be true based on the current evidence
if you see videos on TikTok and Instagram
that need debunking please send them to
me of course it would be great if you
follow me on those platforms as well
if you enjoyed this video click
the like and the subscribe teach
the algorithm that this is what you like seeing
also let me know what other myths you see all the
time that you want me to debunk especially if it's
on silicones I feel like I could probably
make a whole video just on silicone myths
if you want to watch more mythbusting videos I
have a whole playlist here if you want something
a bit less infuriating I also have a
whole bunch of cosmetic science videos